لاكثر من ثلاث سنوات وقوات حركه تمازج
الموقعه على اتفاق جبال السلام تنتظر
تسويه اوضاعها لتصبح جزءا من المؤسسه
العسكريه السودانيه
موقعين سلام تمام الحاجه التانيه ان احنا
هسه حاليا الدوله ما واقفه معانا اصلا
المطلوب ان احنا دايرين الحكومه تجف علينا
وتجد رتب لنا ونحن لو رتبت لنا
النهايه جيش
حركه التمازج تنتشر خصوصا في ولايه
وتامل ان ينتهي انتظارها لتلتحق بالجيش
السوداني
خلافا لهذه القوات فان ست حركات مسلحه
اخرى موقعه على اتفاق سلام جوبا ما تزال
في انتظار تنفيذ بند الترتيبات الامنيه
فالابطاء في اجراءات دمجها داخل الجيش
السوداني قد يضاعف من تعقيدات المرحله
الانتقاليه
داخل هذا المعسكري غربي السودان تستعد
قوات احدى الحركات المسلحه لتصبح جزءا من
قوات حفظ الامن وحمايه المدنيين بدرفور
وهي خطوه تمهد لالحاقها بالجيش السوداني
وفق اتفاق جبال السلام وجود اكثر من خمسه
جيوش في السودان يعني عدم استقرار امني
عدم استقرار السياسي عدم استقرار اجتماعي
ما لم تشكل حكومه مدنيه المجتمع الدولي
سوف لن
يعني يدعم هذه الترتيبات الامنيه والاعطاء
قوه دفع اضافيه لمسار الترتيبات الامنيه
جرى التوقيع على جداول زمنيه محدثه لاتفاق
جبال السلام اتفاق اكد الحرص على جيش مهني
قومي واحد ملتزم بالعقيده العسكريه
الموحده خطتنا
انه نعمل الدم
يتم جزء من يمشي الشرطه
كده يعني
بحتاج الى حاجه الدعم العسكري بشكل كبير
جدا من بين ما يعوق اكمال الترتيبات
الامنيه وتسريع ادماج قوات الحركات
المسلحه ضمن المؤسسه العسكريه ضعف التمويل
الدولي نزار البقدونس